عاش السودان يوما طويلا منذ الصباح تضاربت
في احداثه الروايات بين معسكرين احدهما
الجيش السوداني والاخر قوات الدعم السريع
وكل منهما يلقي باللائمه فيما جرى اليوم
على الطرف الاخر لكن المؤكده وسقوط قتلى
وجرحى من المدنيين حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره
بمقتل ثلاثه واصابه ثمانيه اخرين في
الاشتباكات الجاريه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع قرب مطار الاوبيض كما نقل مراسلنا
سماع عدوي اشتباكات باسلحه ثقيله قرب
القصر الجمهوري ومقر القياده العامه وسط
العاصمه وقال المتحدث باسم الجيش ان قوات
الدعم السريع موجوده بكثافه عندما قرت
التلفزيون الرسمي بينما تدور اشتباكات
مسلحه بين الطرفين في شارع الغابه في
الخرطوم اضافه الى مناطق جنوبيه العاصمه
وبينما اكد مصدر في الجيش استعادته
السيطره على مطار مروي اكد المصدر ذاته
احتمال تجدد القتال في اي لحظه
من جانبها بثت قوات الدعم السريع صور ما
قالت انه اسر جنود وضباط مصريين في مطار
مروي